the impeachment discussion is moving
from Capitol Hill to recreation centers
and schools across the country members
of Congress have been holding town hall
meetings in their home districts this
week CBS News special correspondent and
co-host of the circus Alex Wagner is in
Iowa Alex lawmakers have been pretty
busy during this congressional break
they sure have good morning Anthony as
those lawmakers are debating impeachment
in Washington they are returning home as
well to deal with constituents and make
their case make their case about why
President Trump should be kept in office
or taken out occasional laughter mixed
with some contention in central New
York's 19th district came from a
whistleblower
that's where freshman Democratic
congressman Antonio Delgado heard both
sides of the argument to impeach the
president identify the exact crimes that
as you think happen it is a crime to
solicit any of that from a foreign
national your constituents behind you on
the subject of impeachment I don't you
know I think it's about whether or not
we give truth the chance
understand you were here you were in the
room I think you were in the room dude
people mix the points of view yeah
four-term california congressman and
former Democratic presidential candidate
Eric SWA well talked about the need to
move swiftly laine our concerns the
president and his administration have
poured gasoline on the fire on Staten
Island congressman max Rose is among the
last Democratic holdouts to come out in
support of impeachment in a historically
conservative district we have
Republicans who swore the same oath to
the Constitution that I did but suddenly
they become deaf mute blind
whenever allegations against the
president are brought up that's an even
greater threat to our democracy I beg
your pardon but all of our he's pushing
aside he's making fun of them on Twitter
and ma'am I can't speak for him I know
you can't speak for him but you can
speak for yourself if the house votes to
impeach deciding to remove the president
from office will be up to senators like
Iowa Republican Joni Ernst who is up for
re-election herself in 2020 our Senate
Republicans talking amongst themselves
about their own concerns with President
Trump in this moment well I haven't
visited with others about their concern
be spoken to leaders and we did have a
discussion he made it very clear that
all the information it'll come forward
it'll go to that Senate Intelligence
Committee and then they will sort
through it again in a bipartisan manner
Alex you get any sense that that any
Republicans are breaking with the
president at this point well you know on
Thursday the president seems to suggest
that Mitch McConnell was firmly behind
him in all of this but as you see from
Joni Ernst who is a moderate and
vulnerable Republican heading into 2020
the strategy seems to be much more
wait-and-see you hear her talking about
the Senate Intelligence Committee
investigation so that may not be enough
to remove the president from office if
the house votes to impeach so you need
67 votes in the Senate which is
two-thirds of the upper chamber but it
a developing story Anthony sure is
alright Alex Wagner thanks Alex the
fourth season of the circus continues
Sunday on Showtime a division of CBS
check your local listings